[Music]
in self infected news submitted by can I
join
Joe Mallya they spelled it Joe - Mallya
this man is Cuba's last self infected
HIV Punk rebel why would you self in
effect why would you give yourself AIDS
and is that a punk music thing it's like
a fad or something anybody outside of
like a heroin place and oh that guy oh
yeah no he actually got someone's arm
drew blood and injected in himself why
he coulda just fought somebody with a
that would have been more fun way more
fun why do you do it like that weird
okay you're not even good at getting
AIDS that's a painful way of getting
AIDS
so Jason he's 42 years old right now
yeah yeah bad name that's like you don't
even eat get to eat cake you just get
fat yeah so back in the late 80s early
90s there was this lifestyle group this
punk-rock lifestyle group that they
would call themselves three keys or
freaks in Cuba usually like there's
Punk's around the world like that's
common we see them a lot but this
lifestyle in particular was really bold
in coming this Cuba at that time and so
they like rock music was outlawed and
drugs were like severely policed and so
it was really hard to be a punker in
that time when the Soviet Union fell in
1989 that's when poverty just went like
crazy in Cuba and so a lot of these
punkers might as well kick age then
these freaks they started to own in
order to combat homelessness they
started injecting themselves with AIDS
because there was a lot of stateful
there's a lot of state-funded clinics
and that's where they would seek Haven
because they would get food they would
get taken care of
yeah and then plus they would rather
have a zijn to be homeless maybe they're
too hungry be scrutinize a lot like the
police would [ __ ] with them a lot and so
in order to have like some sort of like
leave me alone they would
go and live in you Abe they just go on
the jungle I think I'd rather go in the
jungle too cuz that's immediately what I
was thinking in Cuba they got bananas
and they got like trees and stuff and I
said I watched the Che Guevara movie
when him and Fidel Castro took over Cuba
and I was like yo this is like camping
every day with your homies it looks
pretty cool I mean yeah that's why they
would infect themselves though because
they found it a lot easier to be in
these clinics and they also they thought
that this disease would be cured quickly
so they didn't realize that they would
have this disease they thought it was
temporary yeah like I'm catching the
cold pretty much so that's kind of like
well maybe if I give myself the flu then
I can just stay in this little hospital
I'm fed and whatever yeah that's how
they saw it as so they didn't know like
what we know today that ages forever
unless you're Magic Johnson pretty much
yeah they would affect themselves to
seek you know safety and also if there's
there was someone that they loved that
had the disease that would affect
themselves to be with that person and so
it's like this guy person he she's seen
like all his friends die from the
disease and it was just there saying
like 3800 why does he want to have it if
he saw his friends die from it no after
he already had it he injected himself 17
years ago [ __ ] and so between 1986
and 2015 there have been three thousand
eight hundred deaths that's a lot of
people dying and then now or like since
the recent count there's still 20
thousand people oh my god in kuba
kankube right now and they still eaten
that the HIV buffet no so that the
clinics they closed in 1994 and what I
do know now they're just there's mad
people ages running around and trying to
get by you gotta close oh when they
started having the drugs like to combat
AIDS but this is Jason and his wife and
she she lost her legs dude ain't do the
Aiden
lose your legs today nobody's taking
care of that lon
somebody's focused that is crazy
can't believe that at least you got that
Ramones shirt on how did he even get
punk music to Cuba I know I kind of want
to know - because it was outlawed and if
they were so poor how did they get it
like on cassette players or whatever or
like yeah what did they had they've even
have cassette players in the 70s right
they had eight tracks and [ __ ] well this
is 80's 90's so he got himself aids in
the 80s yeah man that's so sad dude I
can't even imagine being so [ __ ] poor
to where you gotta choose between giving
yourself a disease or eating another
meal that is pretty crazy
herpes or meal hmm what should I do like
now he's making a living from a small
state allowance and she sells many pure
products but he's considered the very
last self infected freaky oh I thought
you said there was twenty thousand
twenty thousand people with AIDS
yeah they having he was the last one oh
yeah I like he's like the last Punk self
infected free dude that's hella punk
rock like that's like you're so into one
genre or lifestyle bad you're willing to
give up everything for it and the
challenges is real - like in a communist
country delight Oh what you like Britney
Spears will [ __ ] you kill you it's like
you could you could die from a fashion
or a style I can't even imagine that cuz
I'll hear we're like yeah don't dress
this way because your parents don't will
ground you right or like we got our
asses beat for wearing baggy pants or
whatever it was yeah you're really
showing the man it's different in the
system and then you like fight and and
you want to be like a guy with
dreadlocks play bongo drums and [ __ ]
like going to protests and stuff but
then out in those countries though if
you're like doing that [ __ ] it's way
different yeah that's scary
I can't I don't think I'd be fashionable
at all if I grew up in one of those
countries I'd just be like what I could
be I could go to jail for having long
hair well [ __ ] that I'll shave my head
misfit that's a true misfit yeah that's
a real rebel over here that they make us
look like [ __ ] wannabes yeah you guys
heard of this band I don't know their
name like a years ago I saw this
documentary trailer and in that trailer
they were like if we don't make it in
like seven years we're gonna kill
ourselves
yeah have you heard about this oh darn I
was so hoping yes or no but I mean are
they dead no I think they're dead not
but I mean I don't know if they killed
themselves but um I think they're like
punk rockers as well dude that sucks cuz
what if it was their eighth year that
big break woulda came but then they
killed himself on the seventh they chose
the wrong number I know why you choose
seven dude cause it takes at least 10
years to make a big pile dude that's
crazy dude just hearing his story I just
been trying to think like have I ever
like actually induced any harm to give
herself no I don't but I'm just like
wondering if I ever inflicted harm to
myself to get out of anything and I'm
like oh maybe one time like I was like
scratching like somewhere around my body
right here and this is like probably in
elementary school and my mom's like
what's wrong I'm like I don't know it's
just really itchy here and she was like
do you think it's the residue chickenpox
I'm like oh yeah yeah I'm so itchy
everywhere I feel like that was probably
the only time but that wasn't even
moving me inflicting anything it was
like probably literally the residue of
the chickenpox gave my son well I think
I gave myself a fever because one night
I wrapped myself and all these Mexican
blankets and it was like hot in that
time and I woke up the next morning and
in my mom took check my temperature and
I had a few
feels like cooler gave myself beer are
you trying to give herself a fever like
oh sure I wasn't trying to go start the
next oh I did that all the time
I tried boiling water sticking a
thermometer and they're [ __ ] taking
bring it into my shower [ __ ] oh my
god
look at my book it's like a hundred and
thirty degrees or some [ __ ] it's like he
never be hospitalized now I would never
work and in the days that I was actually
sick I will backfire on me it'd be tired
if your mom or he was I'm sure she was
but she's like oh you know what I was
about to surprise you we're gonna go to
Disneyland
she wasn't that smart things like what
our kid gets big I have to buy one of
those police cameras just so I could
catch them to know they're heading
[ __ ] yeah cash your mother's [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] you guys that have
cameras all over the house dude that
would be hilarious lies sex [ __ ] kids
are I know you know I just remember
something that was yesterday's
thermometer today is different just not
today
oh you like so now you know I have to
beat your ass right for lying to me Oh
if you're smart enough you done but you
lied to me too I know
I don't know but wouldn't you get be
poor like back talking to your mom no
I'm saying if I was a parent oh well now
I have to kick your ass as you lied to
me then I'm saying if the kids smart
he's gonna be like but mommy you like to
we're not going to do that no I'm like
[ __ ] lost [ __ ] well I'll be my own
ass I thought that'd be me later in
private which he always does so the kids
your girl thinking oh my god no no amen
oh did you guys enjoyed that episode of
Jessica dnews if you did please leave a
comment down below and share us your
thoughts and your feelings for more
episodes click right up here
[Music]